Attorney General Bill bar sitting down
for a wide-ranging interview with Fox
News earlier today and it's driving the
critics nuts Attorney General Bill Barr
short on specifics long on rhetoric
today this attorney general is the
attorney general of president Trump's
fantasies he acts more and more like the
total mouthpiece of the President it is
more than disappointing absolutely
incredible you know Barr has done
nothing but damage his credibility with
law enforcement I mean you might as well
just slap you know an ex-kgb badge one
our Attorney General disgusting
what did Barr actually say though that
was so controversial well not a whole
lot now he did preview how the
investigation into the investigators
might play out and why well let's unpack
each of the significant takeaways one by
one now it's important for all of you
tonight to understand every bit of this
first here's why bar initiated this
investigation no one's really looked at
it I think there's a misconception out
there that we know a lot about what
happened the fact of the matter is Bob
Muller did not look at the government's
activities he was looking at the whether
or not the Trump campaign had conspired
with the Russians but he was not going
back and looking at the
counterintelligence program second the
AG reveals the more he digs the more
questions
he has I've been trying to get answers
to questions and I found that a lot of
the answers of monadic inadequate and I
have also found that some of the
explanations I've gotten don't hang
together so in a sense I have more
questions today than I did when I first
started he also explained why the nature
of the players behind this campaign to
spy on Trump was unusual even to a
seasoned vet like Barr this was handled
at a very senior level of these
departments it wasn't handled in the
ordinary way that investigations or
counterintelligence activities are
conducted it was sort of an ad-hoc small
group and most of these people are no
longer
of the FBI or the CIA or the other
agencies involved and fourth and perhaps
most importantly Barr reveals why it's
in the public's interest that he pursued
potentially the corrupt origins of the
Russia probe if we're if we're worried
about foreign influence for the very
same reason we should be worried about
whether government officials abuse their
power and put their thumb on the scale
and and so I'm not saying that happened
but I'm saying that we have to look at
that bingo now given the challenges only
someone of Bill Barr stature could
weather the petty political attacks and
actually remain effective when you took
this job did you think Democrats would
make you the target yes you were ready
for that yes I thought I was in a
position where this kind of criticism
really wouldn't bother me very much he's
just completely not affected by any of
this buzzing all around I mean just does
his job and all of this drives the
resistance crazy